لذلك من وجهة نظر
التشخيص ، لا يبدو أن أوميكرون مشكلة يمكن تشخيصها بسهولة
من خلال عرض سريري لا
يبدو أنها مشكلة على الرغم من أنها
الأيام الأولى ومن وجهة نظر العلاج
لا يبدو أنها مصدر قلق
ما قد يكون مصدر قلق  فيما يتعلق بما
إذا كانت اللقاحات ستصمد
ضدها وهناك ما رأيناه في
أحدث المعلومات التي أصبحت
متاحة من معهدنا الوطني
للأمراض المعدية
هو أننا نشهد زيادة في
إعادة العدوى ، لذلك هناك تحليل مبكر
من أحد مراكزنا  تسمى
السمسم
التي نظرت في نسبة
إعادة العدوى إلى الإصابات الجديدة وما
نراه مع omicron هو زيادة
في إعادة العدوى ، النسبة هي 2.4
وهي أعلى مما رأيناه في
موجاتنا السابقة الآن نتوقع بعض
الزيادة  لأن لدينا المزيد من
الإصابات السابقة الآن ولكن هذه الزيادة
بعيدة عن النطاق ، وهذا يعني
أنه يبدو أن العدوى الطبيعية السابقة
لا تحمي
إلى حد كبير
من omac  عدوى رون
على جبهة اللقاح ، ليس
لدينا بالفعل بيانات حتى الآن لم يأت بعد
، ونرى إصابات اختراق في
الأفراد الذين تم تلقيحهم ولكن حتى الآن
كانت خفيفة ولكن لا أريد أن
أقوم بالكثير من هذه الحالات التي لا تزال قليلة جدًا
لإبداء أي تعليق